bonjour et bienvenue pour cette audience
consacrée aujourd'hui aux terribles
espèces mangeuse d'hommes est ce que
vous êtes un mangeur d'hommes non je ne
crois pas
n'est pas mon genre d'homme qui veut il
ya des règles un protocole à respecter
on ne devient pas mangeur d'hommes comme
ça et la première unis craignent le
populiste soit considéré comme une
espèce mangeuse d'hommes et qu'elle
mange de l'homme bien entendre oui merci
captain obvious mais non non ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'elle ne doit manger
que de l'homme et uniquement ça pas
qu'elle s'en fasse un casse dalle une
fois tous les 18 mois pour être un
véritable mangeur d'hommes il faut donc
posséder un régime alimentaire à base de
viande humaine principalement digérer
les cellules humaines et en tirer des
calories doit être une source majeure
d'énergie
on appelle cela une niche écologique
[Musique]
alors quelle espèce fait de la digestion
de tissus humains seul et unique niches
écologiques suspect
et le gagnant est
[Musique]
nebout et oui le pouls comme son petit
nom scientifique en témoigne pediculus
human us est l'une des seules espèces
dont le régime alimentaire est
uniquement composé de tissus humains
il est talonné de près par la puce de
l'homme très proche cousine de celle du
chien tellement qu'il ne se prive pas
d'un petit repas de sang cana il faut de
temps en temps et là on vous parle que
des plus grosses bêtes car en réalité il
ya pléthore d'acariens qui vivent sur
votre peau et se nourrissent de vos
cellules mortes et de vos sécrétions
comme le démo d'aix par exemple si petit
qu'il se loge dans les pores de votre
peau et les politiques pileux mais il ya
plein d'autres espèces qui dans la même
veine suce le sang des êtres humains
mais celle là comme les moustiques par
exemple ne sont pas spécifiques à
l'homme épique tout et n'importe quoi
bon ok les suceurs de sang c'est fait
mais enfin bon je m'attendais quand même
à quelque chose qui s'attaquerait un peu
plus à la viande tu vois quelque chose
qui ferait des vrais dégâts pas des
petits boutons
tu crois que les petites bêtes ne
mangent pas les grosses c'est que tu ne
connais pas les bactéries des virus de
chair oui parce qu'en plus il y en a
plusieurs
elles sont responsables d'une maladie
nommée la fascine nécrosante toutefois
contrairement à ce que leur nom indique
ces bactéries ne dévore pas réellement
la chair mais sécrète des toxines qui
empoisonnent les cellules c'est pas joli
joli à voir
la lucilie bouchère n'est pas mal non
plus dans sa catégorie c'est une bouche
rien qu'une toute petite mouche mais
dans la larve son asticots si vous
préférez ne se nourrit pas de viande
morte est déjà en décomposition comme le
ferait celui de n'importe quel autre
mouche non celui là s'attaque aux chairs
encore vivant c'est assez cool man de la
victime vivante
il s'entraîne au bétail et aux humains
heureusement qu'on en a pas en france
mais détrompe toi cette salle petites
bêtes ne nous vient directement de
guyane française et avec la
mondialisation des transports elle a
failli se répandent à travers le monde
heureusement que les gouvernements des
pays affectés ont rapidement réagi au
lieu de balancer massivement la victime
ce qui n'aurait pour résultat que de
sélectionner les souches domicile il est
plus résistante d'insecticides ils ont
opté pour des lâchers de mouches
mutantes stérile ces derniers sont
rentrés en concurrence directe avec les
mâles fertiles nos mutants provoquant
une chute démographique de l'espèce
mais écolo efficace voilà ce qui
s'appelle une application concrète du
principe de la sélection naturelle
bon c'est pas tout ça mais moi je
m'attendais quand même à voir des
requins des loups des crocodiles enfin
les truqueurs du swag quoi mais c'est
quand même pas de ma faute si ces bêtes
là ne mange pas les gens et ne les tue
que de façon accidentelle
les abeilles de grands prédateurs pack
surmédiatisé sont plutôt anecdotique
en tout cas c'est pas une habitude pour
eux de se nourrir d'humains en france
plus aucune attaque de loup ou l'ours
n'a été enregistré depuis très longtemps
et pour cause puisqu'il n'y en avait
plus et bien que de très rares cas d'
attaques recensées encore dans le monde
les requins ne tue moins d'une dizaine
de personnes par an soit 60 fois moins
que les accidents domestiques impliquant
des chaises les crocodiles et les
serpents sont certainement les plus
maladroits car ils comptabilisent
quelques milliers de morts par an encore
que leur maladresse ce soit comment
dirais-je parfois légèrement provoqué ce
n'est en tout cas pas grand chose
comparé 900 attaques de toutous tueur
tendus et ont 60 mille accidents qui ont
lieu chaque année provoqué par de
gentils biche et 2 millions petit cochon
qui traversent les routes
et tout cela rien que sur le territoire
de ce petit pays qu'est la france
[Musique]
enfin les moustiques rien qu'en tant que
vecteur du paludisme sont responsables
d'un million de morts chaque année tiens
et le cannibalisme et bien il est tout
aussi anecdotique que les attaques de
grands prédateurs
il n'en fait rien à voir avec une niche
écologique ce comportement est le plus
souvent l'oeuvre de jean déséquilibré et
seulement de très rares cas de
cannibalisme de survie ont été
répertoriés quelques sociétés de
pratiquer et le pratiquent encore sous
une forme ritualisé parfois même
uniquement symbolique est toujours dans
un contexte religieux à l'occasion des
funérailles d'un proche ou d'un an et
demi mais les risques sanitaires évident
liés au cannibalisme font que cette
niche écologique n'existe pas et n'a de
toute façon jamais existé et non les
hommes préhistoriques n'était pas plus
cannibale que nous et justement allé
quelques cadeaux cement de
néandertaliens portant des traces
possibles de cannibalisation comme ceux
retrouvés dans la grotte de l'hortus
près de montpellier par exemple laissent
envisager l'existence chez ces derniers
de pratiques funéraires très élaboré
témoignant de soucis métaphysique
proches des nôtres
en fait même les bébés ne vampirise pas
leur maman ils ont beau tirer leur
nourriture de leurs mères via le
placenta ou plus tard ne relaie jamais
aucune cellule de la mer ne va pénétrer
le corps de l'enfant
seuls les nutriments ont filtré en
conclusion à par l'époux et d'autres
petites bêtes
il n'existe pas vraiment d'espèces
mangeuse d'homme juste peut-être des
croqueuses d'hommes occasionnels
l'espèce humaine n'est pas une manne en
tant que niche écologique
à part si vous vous intéressez à un seul
de ses organes il faut dire que faire la
fine bouche en se contentant de se
nourrir que d'une seule espèce c'est
quand même pas évident imaginez que
l'espèce en question disparaissent mais
vu la surpopulation humaine actuelle la
tendance pourrait bien s'inverser et ils
risquent peut-être un jour d'y en avoir
assez pour tout le monde
[Musique]